Une maladie pratiquement
éradiquée en Occident refait
surface. Il s'agit de
la poliomyélite. Et
c'est particulièrement
inquiétant pour les enfants.
Normand Grondin.
- On n'avait pas vu ça depuis
très longtemps : des milliers
de jeunes Londoniens qui
s'apprêtent à se faire vacciner
contre la poliomyélite,
une maladie qui réapparaît,
alors qu'on croyait l'avoir
éradiquée du Royaume-Uni.
La région de New York
est également touchée
depuis trois semaines.
L'éclosion a eu lieu
dans le comté de Rockland,
à une vingtaine de kilomètres
au nord de Manhattan.
se d'eaux usées
du secteur laisse croire
aux autorités de la santé
que des centaines de personnes
pourraient avoir été infectées
sans le savoir.
La raison : le taux national
de vaccination contre la polio
aux États-Unis est de 93 %, mais
seulement de 60 % dans Rockland,
où 11 000 enfants de moins de
2 ans nevaccinés.
BENOIT BARBEAU, professeur, Dép.
des sciences biologiques, UQAM
- Vous savez, on n'entend plus
parler du virus de la polio,
mais là, ce virus-là circule
ailleurs, donc il est endémique
en certains... niveaux limités
dans certains pays.
Contrairement au virus
de la variole, celui-ci
n'a pas été éradiqué.
- La poliomyélite est
une maladie très contagieuse,
généralement asymptomatique,
mais qui cause parfois
une paralysie et la mort.
Les premiers vaccins contre
la polio sont développés durant
les années 50. Leur utilisation
se répand rapidement, surtout
chez les jeunes enfants,
particulièrement vulnérables.
Aujourd'hui, 80 % des enfants
sont vaccinés et seul deux pays,
l'Afghanistan et le Pakistan,
sont aux prises régulièrement
avec des éclosions de polio.
Au Canada, le dernier cas connu
remonte à plus de 25 ans, mais
la ville de New York n'est pas
si loin de nos frontières.
- Ce qu'on doit surveiller,
et c'est ce qu'ils font
en ce moment aux États-Unis,
c'est de s'assurer que
les enfants, entre autres,
qui sont plus susceptibles
à des symptômes graves
si infectés qui ne sont
pas vaccinés, eh bien,
qu'on encourage fortement
qu'ils soient vaccinés.
- Plus de 90 % des enfants
canadiens sont vaccinés
contre l